tiny tina's wonderlands is a standalone
borderlands game building off
role-playing themes from the very
excellent borderlands 2 dlc tiny tina's
assault on dragon keep once again tina
is the bunker master and has players
running through a bunkers and badasses
campaign a tabletop role-playing game
that the crimson raiders like to play
when they're not out fighting bandits
wonderlands leans even more heavily into
d d themes than dragon keep and there's
a bunch of changes from dragon keep and
the borderlands series as a whole so
here's everything you need to know
[Music]
wonderland has a story beyond just loot
and guns although there's going to be
plenty of that the game takes place well
before borderlands 3 which is set seven
years later when tiny tina is around 20
years old that means wonderland takes
place with a younger version of tina as
part of a group of space travelers you
crash on pandora and tina's willing to
take you in and give you shelter as long
as you agree to play bunkers and
badasses with her quite literally inside
one of her bunkers inside tina's
campaign he'll take on the role of the
fatemaker and fight the evil dragonlord
a powerful necromancer who has jacket
notes failed to get rid of heroes in the
world because queen butt stallion and
the party of heroes keeps stopping him
and butt stallion is apparently a
binacorn meaning it has two horns and
rules a capital city bright hoof maybe
it's better if we don't go too deep into
the whole plot thing similar to dragon's
keep though you can expect tina to
change up scenarios as you go playing
alongside you also from the crash
spaceship are prepare for backstory
valentine who sees himself as a dashing
rogue and others see as a washed-up
low-rent space pirate and fret an office
accounting bot turned ship navigator
you'll also see a lot of familiar faces
from borderlands 2 like torg now a half
bard that makes a lot of sense and we
spotted brick in a trailer
though it's a spin-off wonderland still
plays very similar to borderlands games
it departs from the series in both small
and significant ways the biggest changes
are in character creation and class
customization if we look at cosmetics
for example you don't play as a
pre-existing vault hunter instead you
fully customize a character both in
terms of what they look like and which
class they start as your character's
look can be typical or extreme the game
has a slider overdrive option that gets
rid of limitations and lets you do
things like build asymmetrical faces and
exaggerated features you'll also be able
to pick a personality which changes
things your character says those are
gallant clever gruff or strange each
comes with two voice options and you can
even mess with the voice pitch to make
yourself a chipmunk or something like
tabletop role-playing games you'll dump
points into stats for strength dexterity
intelligence wisdom constitution and
attunement these impact things like
critical damage spell cooldown rates
maximum health and other combat related
performance finally you'll be able to
pick a backstory because everybody needs
a good backstory now let's talk about
classes even though you aren't playing a
pre-made vault hunter wonderlands does
still limit you to a starting class
before giving you the option later on to
multi-class being picking another class
to get into as well the six classes are
the berserker who specializes in
freezing and smashing things they can
also do a spin attack with their ex
clawbringer who focuses on fire and
lightning and has a big hammer and a
wyvern companion they pretty much throw
hammers ground pound and give their team
elemental buffs the greatborn focuses on
sacrificing health for area damage
attacks and has a demilitar companion
following them around they're the
typical glass cannon type the spell shot
is a gun wizard which is awesome and do
wields magic or turns enemies into skeep
which are like alien jeep the sport
warden is your typical archer shooting
barrages of arrows and summoning three
frost cyclones the stabilmanser can
either toss out a spinning ghost sword
or go invisible and do critical damage
they're probably the one most similar to
flack from borderlands 3. going further
each of these classes has a class feet
an action skill and a passive skill for
example the grave bourne's class feet is
demilich's companion their action skill
lets them sacrifice health to create a
dark magic blast and their passive can
be leveled to enhance their companions
later in the game players can
multi-class allowing them to unlock and
level traits from other starting
characters you'll be able to do things
like take both the clawbringer and spore
warden's pets at the same time
multi-classing should open up some very
powerful and specific builds guns and
attacks are also going to be different
in wonderland if you play borderlands
you'll quickly notice that many of the
combat mechanics in wonderlands work the
same currently just operating under
different names shields have been turned
into wards magic spells have replaced
grenades rings and amulets boost stats
in the same way as class mods from
borderlands 3 although more can be
equipped now that's not to say it's just
cosmetic differences spells for example
come in a variety of manufacturers and
vary quite a lot in how they behave from
meteor strikes to local area damage
attacks and in some cases rapid fire one
cool detail is that spells have
different hand sigils and flourishes
when they're cast wonderlands does place
a much bigger emphasis on newly added
melee weapons which can stagger enemies
and include a small leaping attack if
you're gonna swing and just miss combat
emphasizes using gun spells and melee
together for maximum effect you can
expect borderlands usual gun loot rarity
pool and in the demo we played we
unlocked a wave shooting shotgun and a
high rate of fire ice spitting smg
elements seem mostly the same with fire
frost lightning poison and the added
dark magic that steals health seems to
be replacing slag and explosive from
previous games like in other games each
element has a specific use such as
poison burning through armor more
quickly and frost slowing and freezing
enemies the other big change is the
overworld the game zones are linked
together by a tabletop inspired
overworld where you walk around as cute
little figurines in third person and
navigate imposing obstacles like cheetos
and soda cans talking to nbc's in the
overworld can lead to entire new zones
which once entered become a little bit
smaller than first-person shooter areas
you're familiar with from borderlands 2
and 3. there'll be random encounters
that you can run away from or take on
for extra loot or just to grind levels
there is an end game in wonderlands and
it's a dungeon called the chaos chamber
the chaos chamber has randomized
challenges that take 20 to 30 minutes to
complete and involve both mini bosses
and larger boss fights players are
limited to three lies but can keep
anything they pick up during that run
even if they die there are over 60 level
layouts and between areas players can
choose one of two portals that gives
them some degree of control over what
they do next one of the larger rewards
if you beat the chaos chamber is the
ability to reroll enchantments on your
gear allowing you to min max your builds
as far as we know wonderland's like all
other borderlands game doesn't have pvp
but it does have co-op and as usual
enemy scale and difficulty to party size
and fantastic news wonderlands will
launch with play and playstation is
finally on board this information came
first from a tweet by randy pittsburgh
and was followed up in a blog post as
before you'll do this through shift
matchmaking pitchford also followed up
that he considered full crossplay in
borderlands 3 to be inevitable that's
pretty rad the game has 2 player split
screen on playstation 4 and xbox one as
well as 4 player split screen on
playstation 5 and xbox series x and s
like in borderlands 3 players can pick
cooperation or coopetation modes with
cooperation each player sees their own
loot on the ground and gear scales to
the level of each individual player this
is great for when high level players
want to team up with lower level friends
coopetition on the other hand drops the
same loot for everybody and the party
needs to divvy up who gets what or fight
over it depends on how much you like
your friends enemies scale to the level
of the host player which can make life
pretty difficult for anybody below level
[Music]
wonderlands has a season pass that kicks
off on april 21st and involves four
content drops over time the season pass
also includes the cosmetic butt stallion
pack the ps5 and xbox series x and s
versions get the dragonlord pack and
players who pre-order get access to the
golden hero armor pack again all these
are cosmetic stuff the four dlcs are
accessed through vesper's mystical
mirrors of mystery which warp players to
new dungeons and boss encounters each
dlc will have a final boss and each
following week a more powerful version
of that boss will appear for players to
fight beating each boss will also unlock
more backstory told by vesper and a
currency called lost souls that can be
spent on vesper's wheel of fate any
bosses defeated in the dlc are also
added to the end game activity the chaos
chamber later on the fourth content drop
will add a seventh class to the original
six in the game
[Music]
there are a few notable voice actors in
wonderland the very talented ashley
birch fresh from her star turn as ailoy
in horizon forbidden west returns to
voice tiny tina she's joined by brooklyn
nine-nine's andy sandberg arrested
developments willarnette and comedian
and actor and writer wanda sykes
[Music]
you should be aware that only the next
level edition costing 70 us dollars and
the chaotic great editions costing 90 us
dollars will come with new gen
optimizations for playstation 5 and xbox
series s and x the standard edition of
60 us dollars is rated for pc on the
epic game store xbox one and ps4
wonderlands is set for release on march
25th with season one in april tiny
tina's wonderlands is shaping up to be
another twisted adventure through the
imagination of an explosively inclined
tween's mind if you want to know more
head on over to gamespot's youtube page
to check out our hands-on impressions of
one of the side areas in the game it
involves a goblin's worker revolt and we
also have 18 minutes of straight
gameplay involving claptrap if you're
into that kind of thing for more videos
about wonderlands including our upcoming
review and which class is right for you
go ahead and stick to gamespot